Let's go to four eight zero, I believe four
eight zero is Arizona.
And given what's going on in Arizona, I would
very much want to talk to somebody there.
A four eight zero.
Who's this?
Where you calling from?
Yeah, this is my name, Steve.
Hey, Steve, are you calling from Arizona?
I and I'm in Phenix, actually.
What on earth is going on there?
Actually, that kind of had to do with one
of my questions.
Actually, I mean, Arizona is actually the
rate is starting to fall ever since deucy
reimposed those restrictions.
Arizona has seen a decline over the past week.
And I kind of feel bad for Deucy because he
gets it from both sides, the right and left,
because we got a lot of right wing nuts in
Arizona.
But that kind of lends itself to my question
to you.
And that's why I've seen a lot of stuff on
Twitter coming from the right about.
Corona virus is being reported two, three,
four times.
Only waiting that people are going and getting
tested and showing up positive when they go
to another hospital and do it again.
Have you have you seen these queens?
And do they hold any water, in your opinion?
Well, so.
So why would someone do that?
If someone gets a positive test at one hospital,
why would they go to another hospital and
be tested again?
Well, they're saying they're doing that to
increase the rate, to make it seem like there's
more corona virus cases in their actual war.
And I mean, this is always.
I gotcha.
But so hold on, Steve.
Who when you say they individuals are saying
I'm going to increase the rate by driving
around and getting multiple tests or someone
is coordinating individuals who once they
find out here, someone with the virus, let's
call them and tell them to keep getting tests
at different hospitals.
Who is that day that is doing it?
Yeah.
Andy Biggs is he's one of our representatives.
He's spreading this information.
Kelly Townsend just, you know, Republican
Arizona lawmakers that have no idea what's
going on.
So they spread this disinformation.
Right.
But my question is, Mike.
My question is, who is coordinating going?
Who whose idea is it to get a person who's
sick to take multiple tests?
Is it the person who's sick or is there some
person on the left who is finding infected
people and suggesting to them that they go
get more tests?
Who's doing it?
That's a good question.
They haven't say Santa Claus.
Because to me, it's all bull crap.
Yeah.
No, listen.
I mean, that's patently absurd.
And, you know.
But by the way, it's not clear that the numbers
really are reversing in Arizona.
There was a decline over the weekend, but
that's typical that over the weekend you see
fewer cases.
The numbers from yesterday are absolutely
brutal.
And I think already today, as we are speaking,
Arizona has again reported 100 deaths.
Like it's actually I don't think Arizona has
has turned anything around yet.
But, yeah, I mean, listen, the more focus
that there is on conspiracy theories, like
sick people are driving around getting multiple
tests, the worse it's going to get because
that's not really going to deal with the virus.
No, I know.
I know I had one more question for you, David.
If you don't mind checking that so has signed
a lot of executive orders during his tenure.
Yeah.
Most notably the Paris Accord.
And my question to you is, can Joe, if Joe
Biden were to get elected, would he be able
to just kind of reverse course and all that
and, you know, kind of undo it sometimes?
And do you think he will?
There's a lot that can be in the same way
that it was done.
But remember that a lot of the things Obama
did, Trump undid by executive order, a lot
of the things Trump did by executive order
can be undone by the next president.
And this is, you know, a lot of times the
debate about executive orders is whether it's
an overreach of power or when should or shouldn't
an executive order be.
The other very practical reality is that a
whole bunch of Trump's executive orders don't
actually do anything.
And they're just a waste of time in the sense
that it's an executive order notifying mayors
that they should prioritize, you know, X.
It doesn't really do anything.
The ones that do something can also very much
be undone by the next president.
This is why we we really need to read this
is part of our broken system, that it's a
lot of just undoing what the previous person
did.
And it's a big waste of time for everybody.
So you don't see him going back into the Paris
accord will have much of an effect?
Oh, no, no.
I'm saying there.
You're saying if Biden comes in and says we're
back in the Paris climate accord.
Right, right.
Oh, no.
That would be a very good thing.
What I'm saying is if it can be easily changed
by the next president, which I thought was
your main question, yeah, Biden can change
that decision immediately.
OK.
That's that's that was my main concern that
was getting the one thing that trumps tone
that has upset me the most was the Paris Accord.
But hey, man, I really appreciate you taking
my call.
I tried calling all the time.
I never get through.
So I appreciate it.
Thank you for continuing to try.
And great to talk to you.
And I hope to hear from you again as well.